Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday. Yeah, I do say Tuesday weird. Deal with it.
If you didn't know, I'm the other Nerd Factor winner
known as NerdyandQuirky. Hi.
Following the pattern formed by previous
videos, I am NOT John.
I'm about as not John as possible.
What I am is a fifteen-year-old living
in the modern era,
experiencing teenage life and noticing all the unfortunate things my peers and I do.
So Hank, I'm here like the ghost in a Dickens novel to warn you about the annoying things
your niece and nephew might do, at least according to [sing song] stereotypes
[sing song] Oprah hands
Friends and social life will basically become more
important than anything else.
I'm not being exclusive to social interactions
that take place in real life, because
[pffh] that would probably involve going
outside and let's be honest.
[as mom] Sabrina, it's time for dinner
Sabrina: [hisses] Not now. Alex and I are rewriting the Book of Mormon.
"Mom": Whaa-
Sabrina: I'll eat later
Diets will range from eating no food the whole day to eating all the food in the world.
Let me tell you, if I'm
left to my own devices, I will forget to
eat the whole day. Until the sound of my
stomach growling is louder than the
YouTube video I'm watching. And then I'll microwave something, probably a bag of popcorn.
Then I'll eat a bag of chips, then some
crackers, probably some cheese.
Then, to counteract how salty that was, I'll
probably eat some ice cream or cake.
There's a science to it. The science of delicious.
Next, they will fangirl. This affects both [*all]
genders. This fangirling may be talking
about people. Said  people may be older
than you. It's kind of weird but don't
worry too much about it. [ding]
[orchestral background music]
Also, there will be a stage in life where
meme quoting is done unironically.
I'm staring straight into the Sun because
YOLO.
Then it's gonna move to its ironic usage.
Made bananas in the toaster. YOLO.
Then this usage will continue, until it once again becomes unironic.
Catching up on current events. YOLO.
There will also be slurred speech.
[slurred] yeah, so I told him to shut up, because communities are really [unintelligible]
...understand quality humor...face...right?
You're so right!
Yeah!
Bad vision.
You are the prettiest thing I've ever seen in ever. No wait,
I changed my mind you are. No wait, changed my mind again.
Trouble breathing.
"Mom": How was your day?
Sabrina: [groans]
Weird, these are starting to sound
like medicine warnings.
As if the very act of aging is like taking medicine. The experience is making us more mature and
intelligent with possible negative side
effects.
[sobbing]
Did I actually just pull a metaphor out
of that?
Yees I did! [high five] [pff] What do you mean it was a stretch? Excuse you, who do you think I am?
John Green? Hank, I'll see you on Friday.